[Musique]
ils sont les entraîneurs de demain c'est
8 bboys et big girl comme on les appelle
se sont retrouvés pour leur deuxième
semaine de formation au centre de la
danse GPSO des Mureaux ils vont obtenir
le premier titre certifiant reconnu par
l'État une ouverture à une
professionnalisation de la discipline
notre projet artistique il est axé
autour justement des Nancy pop et du
breaking donc pour nous ça coulait de
source d'avoir ce type de partenariat et
on est très fier de pouvoir accueillir
cette première promotion en partenariat
avec la Fédération Française de danse et
l'INSEP avec 30 millions de pratiquants
dans le monde et un million en France
depuis 2020 le breakdance est reconnu
comme discipline olympique
c'est sur cette héritage de Paris 2024
que repose la formation est allée sur 10
mois les danseurs vont acquérir les
compétences fondamentales du métier
d'entraîneur viens partir du principe il
y a plusieurs écoles il y a plusieurs
visions voilà qui vont vous être
partagés et que chacun avec ses
ambitsibilités à construire son chemin
c'est une formation qui est assez
intense pour eux qui va leur permettre
une acquisition d'un diplôme de niveau 4
donc le titre finalité professionnelle
TFP avec l'intitulé entraîneur breaking
qui va pouvoir leur ouvrir les portes
d'une carte professionnelle aussi donc
reconnu des institutions
le choix des Mureaux pour la formation
n'a pas été un hasard depuis quelques
années ce secteur constitue une plaque
tournante des danses de rue pour keno du
groupe de break yvelinois première
avertissement cette formation est
l'opportunité pour les breakdanceurs de
voir reconnaître leur travail et de
peut-être entraîner un jour l'équipe de
France moi c'est aussi c'est aussi un
défi que j'aimerais réaliser être coach
de l'équipe de France que ça soit au
niveau espoir pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir travailler avec la nouvelle
équipe qui représentera la France pour
les prochains JO habituez-vous à voir
ces figures car la discipline regorge de
talents qui comptent bien nous donner le
tournis pour les JO de Paris 2024